mieux dompter squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur une tête ces partis
religieux ok on est sur une tête comme
je sais et c'est un jeu que je veux at
il menti c'est parce que le concept à
ses parents en fait nous on est une
sorte de menu ou probablement au jogging
gris nike bon j'en sais rien mais en
bref on doit aller tout là-bas sans se
faire buter voilà il ya un mec qui nous
chasse qui nous traquons sniper et le
but c'est d'aller le plus loin possible
c'est la première version du jeu qui
était extrêmement difficile ils ont fait
une deuxième version un peu moins dur et
stop it stop it s est super stressant
c'est horrible ils vous rappellent comme
ça qui lève sa tête d'un caillou le but
c'est déjà le cas où là bas je suis mort
mais attends mais c'est un tireur
d'élite quoi qu'est ce qui se passe mon
gars qu'es-tu affaires question affaires
bitches mais j'aimerais bien savoir où
il est en fait il est pas là bas dans la
maison tout là haut je sais pas on voit
passer ce qu'est ce qui est encore plus
stressant tellement ça soit je la fuis a
parlé ok pas mal danger bon on n'est pas
si bien alors j'ai laissé mes gars non
non tu dit ça mon gars qu'est ce tu dit
ça je te nag à à de merde
elle a l'expérience le mannequin bien
fait un stage avec un délit je peux dire
ma blague
il a fait un stage de tireurs d'élite et
avec adibou ça c'est clair et net à
messieurs orange ça attendez je sors
gerima il a tué d'une balle dans doigt
de pied quoi j'avais rien d'autre que
doit payer sa sortie de ce mur non mais
en plus mon coeur à chaque fois que je
meure il fait beau ça m'a frôlé à ce mec
vole un peu à faut que j'aille là-bas
français je peux me cacher des à celui
son
la réponse est bien évidemment non mais
c'est méga tueur et si je fais pas les
steaks
je vois quel genre d'homme est hué
jackson parce que tout le monde appelle
jackson mais [ __ ] de vidéos n'empêche
qu'on médias d'être regardés on dirait
que j'ai des rollers quoi lalalalalala
[ __ ] faut que je passe lalalalalala
acheter des lunettes est le principe du
jeu est quand même bien drôle quoi vous
le voyez vous si quelqu'un voit cet
homme là on sait on s'est enfermés
malheureusement 1
il va falloir être tactique no no no à
sa meute et [ __ ] qu'est-ce qui se
basent votre toit a gelé vu j'ai vu j'ai
vu le bout de son sniper s'éclairer
généralement quand tu vois ça tu meurs
une demi-seconde après la mort de chien
est-ce que ce soit pour un commando
américain itunes ipod at the top of the
call in his wiesinger slightly tel mouse
and round ok mon but c'est de te repérer
pour mieux de châtier mon enfant rien la
lie croit m
ah bah si tu as ça m'énerve métier pas
quoi faire le gros noob à aller sur la
version plus facile parce qu'on est trop
mauvais je t'ai vu mon gars je t'ai vu
je t'ai vue on peut peut-être le voir
faudrait qui tient un coup je pense
qu'il est dans la maison tout là haut le
mec ou alors ça se trouve il est même
pas dans le jeu en fait il est là haut
dans le ciel
la droite y à quoi un rocher je vais me
mettre à l'abri des ailes aux cailloux
aux courageux ce réflexe incroyable
[ __ ] beatbox peur il faut qu'on prenne
notre courage à deux mains
aymeric design de kia pop the c'était
une femme
tard il voit même les fans qu el mekki
carnot trop fort mais je leur fais au
papa papa papa s'était fait embaucher
j'ai commencé là j'ai terminé là encore
moins bien quoi attendait on attendait
pas finalement on va embaucher 20 papin
face à la barre d'un pas et willy bell
où aller nous y ait ce week end of low
donc non ça met une pression de deuil
c'est génial comme idée sans déconner
assez génial tu es d'accord avec nous
pas moins de poids coq à sa place comme
ça mais la vraie ya rien de pire quand
tu espères que par apple qui fait ça
dans ton visage à aller la pire tu es
d'accord on pense au foot d'accord banon
mais c'est évidemment là mais à chaque
fois je suis une fan je vous demande un
truc pour qu'ils me répondent xad
consenti répond pas de manière ce mec
est silencieux non non non non non non
non non non non non non non non non non
non technique l'arbre à pain mais [ __ ]
déjà mal aussi pour mon gars on atteint
la route
quelle est la stratégie à adopter est-ce
qu éventuellement foncière ce grillage
ou le coup de manière à faire un trou on
passe puis on s'enfuit [ __ ] j'aimerais
bien faire ça dans les chiottes en plus
il nous aura dans son viseur à ce salon
il est bien placé les mieux placés ce
faux billets bien placé au le saut on va
arrêter de narguer ok donc c'est parce
que je disais dans les maisons tout l'
or la ola autant c'est vraiment qui rate
son coup voilà bien comme ça on atteint
là dès l'étape
ok j'étais mobile et ne tue pas quoi non
mais attends c'est une blague cauchon en
train de bouger comme une vipère issil
s'emballer ce thème qui me tue par
contre dès que free mobile n'a d'abord
subi au débat la semoy vie [ __ ] de la
kaaba mais qu'est ce que tu fous dans ta
cavale là bas au fond là bas au fond
dans la cabane se trouve est un homme
attire des ligues professionnelles
tuer des gens et moi je vais me cacher
derrière cet arbre la technique de merde
il tire à travers la remet ça le
transperce ça me tue c'est bon c'est
bien c'est bien c'est bon ça s'est très
bien passé jouissif choléra team [ __ ]
tir je vous jure
donc c'est bon c'est bon il a tiré sa
balle le temps qui est charge on est
presque
le mieux est de plus en plus petits quoi
bientôt il y aura juste une brique comme
ça posé à la verticale sera logée
derrière comme des groupes-cours houénou
turin et pourraient être sérieuses le
mur herbe
as tu peux pas mais des plus tôt c'est
là qu'il faut se lancer y est ça
marchait non non pas maintenant pas
maintenant iam sony ce but
vous avez vu à temps j'essaie de calais
des petites phrases en anglais mais ça
marche pas trop bon donc non ça près de
cailloux je vois la tête du milieu il
est moche et semble un doigt est un peu
c'est bon enfin papa papa papa
oh non mais attends mais ouest qu'est ce
que je disais bientôt y aura juste une
brique quoi et là je peux pas creuser
dans ce [ __ ] de sol atebede aouicha
pardon je trouve jouer à des jeux
d'infiltration ok mais là on fait quoi
avec
on est père dieu regardez aux milliers
d'annoncés suivre la route ya une
colline il pourra plus nous visent et
alors maaf à la fin des fins
yes yes yes yes yes yes [ __ ] mais si
on y arrive là c'est la difficulté
maximale c'est même pas facile on a
réussi au [ __ ] t'es la danseuse mais
arrête
elle ne voit pas non mais sans déconner
arrête tu vois juste de l'herbe là après
peut-être que tu as peur de l'air j'en
sais rien arrête comme j'aime m'abriter
des instrus que la baratte c'est bon il
faut que je fasse quoi c'est quoi le but
c'est de sound est dans la voiture c'est
quoi ou le but et déclarations de
circonstance avec une musique et tout le
bordel
non là là je te plante j'te défonce
t'es où théo dans cette [ __ ] de maison
un maintien s'est installée
ouais bah non mais c'est bête le tireur
s'est prouvé qu'elle perde pas [ __ ] de
foire et ados qui était bien là depuis
le début
regardez on voit bien tout le [ __ ]
c'est ça c'est un sniper oui comment de
ce truc à distance quoi et on a quand
même terminé le jeu dans sa difficulté
maximale son entraînement avec annie
boulât deux tireurs d'élite mais voilà
sont en fait on va aller se détend tout
de suite sur un jeu bien plus des tentes
à se relaxer un petit peu on est donc
sur moine zen un jeu où en fait on peut
tout simplement volé et je vais
peut-être faire le tuto 1 ça serait une
bonne chose avec la petite musique et
tous regardés au square au paradis c'est
tout mignon
jobs à boutons pop wes hamas est si je
tombe dans le vide je vais vomir sans
déconner avec l'oculus c'est vraiment
mon job à boutons space barre non ok ok
ok ok non attendez attendez je sais pas
si je suis prêt à ça c'est pas mon ami
la revue stroke au [ __ ] de merde
haas a déconné avec le cul c'est quelque
chose alors clim big ben perso les crocs
du broker sont enflammés oui oh [ __ ]
mais j'ai vomi avant la fin de ce jeu
quoi enfin pente en france n'entend pas
les ont été complètement c'est compliqué
à ce qui se passe ça ne nous arrêtera
pas
rien ne nous arrêtera à part ma nuque
est en train de se casser voilà c'est
pourquoi au nom un je joue ma vie je me
ok on l'a fait aux allées fin du tuto
haut ça donne une deuxième chance à des
causes et aux échalotes mon camp et
comprend plus rien le chaos né ou le
paradis et dans l'espace t ou non mon
petit corps de là je suis dans mon
bureau et du coup là on peut s'éclater
c'est ça assez génial qu'est ce qui se
passe mon gars à apa jimbo mickey ce qui
se passe au regard des on dirait une
petite entrée on dit qu'il ya une
embuscade qui nous attend là-bas je ne
sais pas des bandits qui vont sortir des
bisons qui ont fait alors comme ça on
vole monsieur tellement que cette
affaire n'est pas la loi qui n'existe
pas au pl oui ça déconne vraiment bien
avant la fin
des anges qui me parle chaque fois que
je prends un chemin on prend le chemin
non non à la gerbe aillent bon france
mais quel âge etc aux pollens il est
mort ça j'annonce géré blanc bienvenus
ici nous faisons vomi en toute gratuité
l'abaya un pimp son regard derrière la
belle avait un truc et ça est ce que
c'est un gentil mot vite il se serait
pas mal hop là j'ai toujours la gerbe
level max ça il faut que j'arrête les
gens sont décotés oui ça fait tourner la
tête
vous savez très bien ce que je veux dire
à ce moment là de la vidéo que c'est
déjà la fin voilà et c'est ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas un fait et spider man avec
votre langue voilà votre langue pour
vous votre planque fait trois
centimètres jeu sera bien moins amusant
que l'autre quelle langue va remettre
merci d'avoir regardé on se retrouve
très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo tient
tout le monde